617 830 for 750 is the number very
varied topic so far on the show and
that's because we are not screening
calls in advance we are just asking for
name in town named in town for the next
caller who's on with us hello arm yeah
well yes you're on the air how long yes
uh hello David my name is Victor Lopez I
live in California and I want to ask you
um why do you think that a lot of the
presidential candidate aren't really
talking about the new trade agreement
that TI SI trade in services agreement
yeah why aren't they talking about it
will there's really no advantage to
talking about it I mean it's sort of
similar to uh why aren't they talking
about the fact that automation and
artificial intelligence are going to
destroy jobs no matter whether Trump or
Hillary Clinton or whoever going to
bring jobs back from China or send jobs
to China or whatever there's just no
benefit to that and they clearly know
now that the trade and services
agreement is not on the minds of most
Americans and there's probably more risk
to starting to talk about it you're
talking about something that's complex
you're putting something in people's
minds instead of talking points that
have already been focused group text
tested etcetera etcetera I think that
there's just no upside to talking about
that I know that Donald Trump has made a
big deal out of talking about how he'll
get us out of the bad trade deals or
whatever but even his knowledge of that
is is only relatively superficial so I
just don't think either candidate has
any any a upside to talking about that
all right well I was also wondering why
you think maybe Bernie Sanders maybe he
should probably wage rate a little
awareness about it you know hey by all
means I mean that you know Bernie
Sanders platform is not what it was when
he was still in this so I think to the
extent Bernie Sanders wants to discuss
it it's absolutely great I think
corporate media has more more basically
moved past Bernie Sanders so I don't
know how much traction he'll get but
absolutely something that should be
discussed thank you so much for the call
really appreciate it